elle s'est mariée à belhadj et miss aube
je l'appelle maymou et lui c'est mon mon
papy m'a juste si on est chez eux pour
la semaine marquée super ici
ça faisait longtemps que je voulais
passer du temps avec toi j'avais pas vu
ta mamie si heureuse depuis les ailes
ici on se couche à 9h30
après ça il faut plus bouger de votre
chambre bonne nuit
c'était quoi mamie mais c'était quoi
merde je crois que mam il va pas bien ta
grand mère est en pleine forme
papy et mamie fondé drôle de truc je
savais que vous alliez m'appeler et
c'est un peu bizarre cette eau pourquoi
elle regarde au fond du puits salut
papy maman il ya quelque chose qui va
pas chez papi et mamie son vieux jeu le
nettoyer c'est tout y'a quoi de la
remise mammy mammy tu es là est ce que
tu veux bien entrer dans le four pour le
nettoyer les maliens